my name is James Morton and I'm the head
of nutrition for Team Sky 2016 is a big
year for us and when we were looking for
a new nutritional partner we wanted a
partner who really does put science into
sport because of course that's the
philosophy of Team Sky is really looking
for those marginal gains and for me
there was only one company around the
could do that because science and
support are one of the few companies who
really do put science into the products
of work with science in sport for a
number of years now in research so I
know their company really well and all
of the products I know how serious they
are by putting science into the products
and of course when it comes to banned
substance test in science and sport
really are leading the way then the only
company that I know of who actually test
the raw ingredients and of course the
outward products so for us as Team Sky
that's very important to really quality
assure the processes and science and
supporter truly leading the way in sport
nutrition at the minute our philosophy
of team sky is really to start with the
demands of the event and ask ourselves
the question what does it take to win
this particular is so even though we're
looking at the profiles of the Tour de
France for 2016 and we're looking at how
these profiles change from day to day
some of the stages may start with the
claim some of the stages may finish with
the claim some of the stages might be
harder to fuel a particular points so
we're actually breaking down each
steered spy stage and try and sell our
nutritional strategies so for instance
if it is a particular client that's
going to be a real hard climb and
unimportant for the risk when can we
feed caffeine in relation to that claim
if the risk starts with the claim what
should we have for breakfast if we're
struggling to get 60 70 80 grams of
carbohydrate per are in because of the
logistics who can we have on the side of
the road to do an extra feed it might be
a gel the writer can just pick that up
quickly when they go past so really
there's a lot of plan on the calls into
steers by steves nutrition but I think
that really makes a difference on race
day
you